we are going down a very slippery slope
Where We Are beginning to celebrate
weakness and losing more than we do
strength and money I'm not going to call
him she because he wants to call himself
of course he does not she
say how can you be a leader if you can't
even say what a woman is
who's going to follow you who's going to
take your lead I've changed my mind on a
few things with kovid because the
science changed I think that was
um it was everyone slightly lost their
mind and people will say well you're
banging on about Freedom where were you
for the freedom of people to espouse
these you didn't agree with on Kobe and
it's a tricky one when a lot of people
are dying but of course the whole point
of fighting for freedom is sometimes a
lot of people die for Freedom have you
always had this thick skin
yeah I don't know I think my only real
talent is Thanksgiving it's importantly
that thrives on conflict person
absolutely love it
why this is fun gonna piss off all the
right people so gloriously and who are
the right people to piss off this
um wokies
wokies are the world's most ludicrous
people now
foreign
ometry on location from our favorite
restaurant IL Portico on Kensington High
Street I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
guest today has been a long time coming
he's a journalist an author Pierce
Morgan welcome to trigonometry
you've offended the entire staff in here
we were just talking about Italian
actors just before yeah yeah but listen
welcome first of all one of the
questions we always ask our guest is who
are you now you're one of the most
famous people we've ever had on everyone
knows Piers Morgan well I think actually
not many people know who you are your
backstory how you come to be sitting
here talking to us so tell us that well
I mean I grew up in a Country Pub down
in the South Coast a little village
called Fletching a tiny village went to
the primary school my parents owned
around the pub and I think my most
formative memory of that was they did
the bottling up where you replace all
the empties and you go in it it'll all
be stinking of booze and and
everything else and you would go in
there and you'd get all the stuff from
the seller and you'd replenish all the
empties they know what it's like in here
and um I actually got a warning from the
school to my mother I was six
and we're just a little bit concerned
that Peters is smelling of alcohol
so and that was an early an early
formative memory really uh going back to
cigarettes for Americans by the way
thanks or cigarettes over there yes yes
nicely pointed out
um but I grew up in I had a very nice uh
upbringing we didn't have uh
particularly loads of money but we had a
lot of love in the family
um before three siblings or four of us
um lovely Village lifestyle local
lifestyle moved to the next door Village
I had two types of Education one feed
paint I was 13 and then stay educated
from 13 to 18. I think they can either
give you a chip on both shoulders or a
chip on either shoulder I think I went
with the latter where I've always found
the great benefit of being educated in
two different ways in two different
environments one very exclusive and one
very non-exclusive is it's allowed me to
probably a bit like you guys I think sit
down with anybody whether it's Nelson
Mandela or the Dalai Lama which I've had
the pleasure of doing meeting the queen
or just the average guy on the street
you know I I don't have any highfaluting
desire to be with Rich and Famous
powerful people any more than they do
people that I meet on the High Street
and have a chat with so I think that
comes from my upbringing in my education
and then I went to journalism College I
had an absolutely clear idea from the
age of about six or seven I wanted to be
a journalist which is a great asset six
or seven yeah my mom remembers me
reading the Daily Mail which was the
baby which may explain a lot of things
um and then email from cover to cover
avidly age six or seven and studying
headlines I mean it's a weird thing for
a six or seven year old kid to be doing
but I was fascinated by news only with
my daughter this morning suddenly
produced the house newspaper I went
watch this and she's done a whole
newspaper aged 11 based on the events in
our house mainly centered around the two
kittens we've got and the drilling next
door where she seems almost Psychopathic
and had a desire to deal with these
Builders but interesting to see her do
that one of my sons did the same thing
around the same age so there's clearly
something in the in the jeans there um
but yeah I was fascinated by news very
nosy very curious
um wanted to get answers to things and
loved the idea of being first with
information and that's never left me I
have an absolute craving it's why
Twitter is perfect because Twitter you
can be first with everything someone
someone's gonna tell you before anybody
else if you just catch the tweet at the
right moment and I think that's why I
love the immediacy of something like
Twitter because for me it feeds my
addiction which is news so uh then I
just went I think the rest is probably
well known I went on to local newspapers
at The Wimbledon news
had a great time there
um funny enough the the news editor of
the sun who was the guy that I who first
gave me shifts in Fleet Street he died
last week a guy called Tom Petrie
incredible guy brilliant news editor
wonderful with young people and he
always encouraged me I couldn't
understand why he was always so
encouraging but he was always so
encouraging every time I call peers like
I was his best mate how are you blah
blah blah what have you got for me like
give him a little local Wimbledon
stories sometimes because it was London
you get a good one and they'd pay you
for it I was excited you get a big check
from the Sun then they gave me some
shifts it was only later I discovered
that there were two Piers Morgan
that I've met about three others there's
about five of us in the world the others
keep very quiet for obvious reasons but
um but Tom Petrie's real mate was a guy
called Piers Morgan from Kent who was a
photojournalist who had regularly given
him stories for years so he thought it
was him ringing up just sounding a bit
more fresh voice
and then we started getting each other's
payments it was like what's going on
here I didn't do that anyway that was
the story of two pairs of organs but Tom
was great and he got me onto the paper
and that was when Kelvin McKenzie uh the
the legendary notorious beast of the sun
ran it and it was you know probably one
of the most brutal journalism schools
imaginable albeit always laced with
extraordinary high-octane energy and
humor and a lot of people that went
through the Kelvin McKenzie's son went
on to edit newspapers I mean I would say
probably more journalists became editors
from that from that reign of terror than
any others which will play slightly into
what we may come to later about my view
that as workplaces get softer and softer
because everyone starts bended all the
time it's upset you're not allowed to
shout at people or berate them even
criticize people anymore uh the downside
of that is that for people with my
personality I found it a fantastic
environment to work in I wanted to stick
I didn't buy a bit of carrot but really
I wanted the stick to drive me to be
better so um that was that and then I
got made out of the news the world at 28
by Rupert Murdoch that was a crazy time
he flew me out to Miami we walked along
Miami Beach in the surf for a few hours
I had no idea what I was doing there and
then he introduced me at a fox
Affiliates party that night to somebody
else as the new editor of the news the
world his biggest selling paper that's
how I found out he literally went this
is my friend Pierce from London he's
here
and then no negotiation nothing no
nothing wow I literally found out when
he turned to the person the next minute
party went he's a new editor of the news
of the world that's a powerful way to to
be to be able to be in the world in his
position the kind of thing Rupert
Murdoch's done his entire life you know
he's a Maverick and he backs himself he
backs again a great lesson backs himself
you know he always he once said to me
that he'd gone against his gut instinct
three times each time it had gone wrong
and he said the trouble with that is if
you go with your gut instinct you've
only got yourself to blame if you're
wrong when it's not your gut instinct
it's somebody else's and it goes against
your gut and it's wrong then you want to
blame other people
different mentality
um and that was great and then I I
defected to the Daily Mirror and nearly
10 great years there and then uh got
fired and pretty
um big circumstances the Iraq photos
Scandal as some people put it
um and then I wanted a television Simon
Cowell took me out over here actually at
the Belvedere in Holland Park and he he
said he was thinking of launching a new
talent show and did I want to be on it
and interestingly that it was Britain's
Got Talent
he was thinking about but it wasn't
called that it was going to be called
Paul O'Grady's Got Talent little secret
for you Paul O'Grady was the biggest
star at ITV at the time along with Simon
and what do they call it Paul O'Grady's
Got Talent and all the acts would be in
the audience and we did a pilot and it
was me Simon and fern Britain of all
people who used to be on this morning
and we did this
um pilot fantastically successful and it
was all about to be greenlit my comeback
was assured prime time TV two fingers to
the world who'd been reveling in my
downfall and um
Paul O'Grady fell out with ITV told them
to go stuff themselves defected to
channel 4 project died
end of comeback before it even started
and then I got a text six weeks later
than Simon saying I sold the Got Talent
format to NBC in America and they've
repackaged it as America's Got Talent
immediately to me went what a great idea
and uh I can't be on it because of
American Idol he said so I'm trying to
think who I who do I know is arrogant
obnoxious vile enough to step into my
shoes and your name is obviously
immediately sprung your mind and three
weeks later I was on the set of the
Paramount movie lot on Melrose in Los
Angeles uh I'd rented a Aston Martin
just for the sheer hell of it so I could
drive my Aston Martin to the famous
Melrose Gates of the Paramount movie lot
and I drove through these famous old
movie backdrops thinking what am I doing
here how has this happened I got to a
trailer next to David Hasselhoff who was
one of the judges and that was that show
went to number one I then did Celebrity
Apprentice with Donald Trump I had the
first series of that I won it so I got
to know Trump who then became president
of the United States of course
um and then I'd replace Larry King at
CNN for fortunately four years I had a
great time doing that and then left
there and came back to UK to do the
morning show and then had to leave that
not quite how I would have wished um
because Meghan Markle didn't like me
disbelieving her which now seems quite
extraordinary I would have thought now
I'd be probably let go for for believing
her
um and that was that uh and then you
know here I am now at all TV here Fox
Nation America Sky News Australia with a
show called Piers Morgan uncensored back
working with a guy that gave me the the
big break in the first place so it's
been a full circle so that's a long
version of my story but that's it no
it's it's very interesting and one of
the things you touch on there is you're
someone people will like or dislike or
whatever you're someone who has dealt
with in his life with a number of big
setbacks some self and some self uh
inflicted some not right people would
none of which actually when I look back
turned out to be a setback so the key
theme I would say remember Kelvin
McKenzie said to me the most annoying
thing about me was that he would scream
at me until his eyes were popping his
neck veins were bulging you know almost
wanting to physically hurt me and then
because I've done something wrong and
then I come back an hour later the big
grin on my face and say I've got a great
skin needs to really annoy him my
ability to bounce back but I've always
taken the view what's the point
wallowing in what's just happened and
even more so change the narrative right
if you had a setback or a negative in
any part of your life then change the
narrative everyone's no one really cares
after about a week even if you're
involved in the biggest story in the
country like Gary didn't care right all
over the papers for a week whatever I
can guarantee in a week's time nobody
cares told him that just get on with it
because no one cares right and if you
lose a big job people give you about a
week or they care then they moved on
um so the best thing to do is change
your own narrative find something that
will change that story that you're just
washed up has been which I've had a few
times and show them you're not but peers
there is a sensitive side here as well
so for instance you're gonna try and
make me cry
turn you into a West Ham fan mate that
would make me cry but so for instance
with Good Morning Britain where you
walked off there's a lot of people who
said that were staged I don't think it
was no no no and that wasn't that also
wasn't why I left I mean many American
viewers of this will probably still
think I walked off and never came back
if I only walked off for about 10
minutes because it was either that or I
was fairly sure I was going to whack the
weather guy on TV which would have been
great Telly not a great idea
um and he was the deputy weather guy too
which was even more ignominious
um no it was I was a bit fired up about
the reaction to my critique of the
Meghan Markle Harry Mega Oprah Winfrey
wineathon because I felt instinct
interval is Right a lot of what they
were saying was simply not true and I
wasn't going to buy into the narrative
that the royal family or a bunch of
callous races just because these two
said so for their own Financial game and
I think history has proven me to be
pretty spot on with that
um but it was all building building the
mob came online and the mob got to my
bosses and my bosses crumbled and they
also crumbled because Meghan Markle
wrote to the female chief executive of
ITV I meet my top boss and demanded she
find me that happened overnight and so I
was told no either you apologize or you
can't come back I said well I'm
apologizing for
I said I mean it I said no we know you
did but can you not just say sorry why
for something I believe I don't believe
her I don't think she's telling the
truth why would I apologize for that
honestly hell belief I thought living a
democracy aren't we I don't have to
believe people do I is it written in my
contract thou Must Believe Meghan Markle
princess Pinocchio and she opens her
mouth no thanks
um it was a very strange thing to be
going through in a supposed Democratic
Society that I was basically being
shoehorned into a place where they knew
I wouldn't apologize so I had to leave a
show that at the moment I left was now
the most watched show on breakfast TV in
the country we finally beaten the BBC
with this great Holy Grail and I thought
we'd get to it it was absolutely on fire
ratings through the roof everyone
talking about us everyone tuning in to
get my opinions which I had been
specifically hired to express in a
straight up manner literally when they
launched me on Good Morning Britain they
used Sympathy for the Devil by The
Rolling Stones as my comeback music
because I've done a week's trial which
went chaotically well and then when I
came back the the people of Britain were
told basically the devil was coming back
because of my opinions and yet for
having those opinions honestly hell that
in the end began the reason I had to
leave
and so how much of what you do is
actually calculated how much of it is
you thinking right I can say something
in a more provocative fashion which I
know will get a bigger reaction and how
much is what you say what you would just
say to your friends no I said no I'd say
I'm exactly the same on air as I'm in
the pub with my mates I'm the same I can
be just as obnoxious I can be just as
offensive sometimes
um depending on their Viewpoint so
remember people are offended if they
don't hear something they they agree
with right that's the era we're now
living when I was young never like that
you could all just Gob off in the pub
and that was accepted we'd all have
different opinions and we'd all get
drunk together and go I'm quite happy
now it's like people just exist in weird
bubble tribes they only really want to
hear
the same views that they believe they
have but as I would say to them how you
do expect to evolve or change your views
or adapt or move with facts if you're so
intransigently stuck in your drive makes
no sense to me but that's where we are
and it's a dangerous place for a
democracy to find itself
um how do we get here Pierce because you
mentioned the Meghan Markle thing as
well and it's just like everything is
racist now and that's not to say that
there aren't racist people I am someone
who's a first generation immigrant I
know they're racist people in this
country but I don't remember a time when
you know office air conditioning was
sexist and this was right and ever ever
it's ridiculous but how did this happen
well the most ridiculous example I can
give you wasn't actually me although I
was accused of being racist for
disbelieving Meghan markers truth which
was a lie which seemed to be
Preposterous and obviously my critique
have heard nothing to do with her skin
color and everything to do with the fact
she was telling a bunch of Whoppers
about the royal family and causing them
enormous damage
um but the worst thing was Shar who was
at the time co-hosting a show called The
Talk on CBS happy for 10 years very
successful
um and I'd been on the talk many times
and she tweeted that I was entitled to
my opinion she didn't say she agreed
with him
so I was entitled to my opinion
and he was then set up on her show so
Cheryl Underwood who was one of the
black hosts of of the talk basically
played the race card and the incredibly
unpleasant manner deliberately to to try
and gotcha Sharon and basically made out
that she accused her of of supporting
somebody who'd said racist things so
Sharon kept saying what are you talking
about what did he say it was racist
and she couldn't answer it what did he
say that was racist he said racist
things and eventually we may not have
said racist things but you know he's
thinking you know in other words if I
didn't believe Meghan Markle who's from
a biracial couple you know white father
black mother if I didn't believe her it
had to be because I was racist
and it was the extraordinary thing
Sharon then lost her job over this
because she reacted so angrily to the
suggestion that I was a racist and
therefore she was supporting a racist
none of that was true
and so to your point that's where we are
how did that happen how did we get here
in your opinion because you would have
seen this in your lifetime I've seen it
in my life identity identity politics is
the biggest problem mixed with a society
that now values and celebrates
victimhood
and weakness and losing over
previous generations who valued higher
strength winning resilience and all
those things that's what's happened so
you now see a ridiculous situation with
the gymnast Simone biles uh who in the
Olympics pulls out of the team
competition and she's obviously the Star
talent for the Americans and the
Russians end up winning it because she's
you know having anxiety issues makes a
dramatic recovery three days later to
take part in the individual comes third
and she normally wins all the goals
comes third and really it's because
she's just slightly lost her power she's
just not as good as she was that's the
real problem and she knew it she tumbled
a couple of times in the team
competition and it freaked her out that
she isn't as good as she used to be in
my opinion but she turned the whole
thing into a mental health this was all
about mental health all about her brave
anxiety you know facing down her brave
issues uh like anxiety and so on and
everyone celebrated it should cover of
every magazine becoming third and for
bottling it in the team competition and
letting her teammates down so they lost
and then recovering in time to take part
in their own thing and I've learned to
notice I went we've all got nuts how can
she be celebrating more for losing and
coming third and falling over and
letting down her teammates than she did
when she won all the goals and it's
funny Michael Johnson the brilliant you
know 200 and 400 meter Runner he pipes
up on Twitter at me as a girl at me for
suggesting that winning bronze is not
somehow the greatest thing of all time
but if it's so great how come your
Twitter name is MJ gold in your Twitter
bio all you mention are your gold medals
because of course he doesn't celebrate
Lucy that's why he's Michael Johnson the
Usain Bolt as a bronze medal dangling on
his toilet wall of course he doesn't
right so we've moved away now from
what I think is important in life which
is that you understand that the more you
work the harder you put in the more you
get back and actually winning's a good
thing in life in all aspects of life
whether it's relationships or you know
work or
friendships whatever it is or sport
anything
winning is not a bad thing it's a good
thing competition is a good thing you
know being able to lose and get back up
and think that sucked I don't want that
to happen again you know Alex Ferguson
at Manchester United used to say to his
players when they lost a big a big title
race
don't ever forget how you're feeling
right now and don't feel that again
you didn't go well don't lie to your
loss you lost to Arsenal let's all go
party
a Time celebrate losing and being a
bunch of losers that's not how he got to
be the most successful coach in history
but we are going down a very slippery
slope Where We Are beginning to
celebrate weakness and losing more than
we do strengthen winning and that's part
of the problem so the relationship to
all the racism and sexism and your
transphobic all that kind of stuff that
goes on now about everything it's
because people can ident they want to
identify as part of these tribes they
want to be part of the trans activist
tribe which means anyone who says
anything about any issue involving trans
people is immediately transformed if you
raise any concern at all so if a male
rapist puts his hand up as he did in
Scotland and says I'm now a woman so I
want to be in a woman's prison talking
to attack other women and get an easier
time than I wouldn't of Men's prison
everyone goes absolutely right and
proper that you should be in a women's
prison until we all go hang on this is
completely insane and the woman who was
buying it Nicholas sturgeon firstman of
Scotland has to lose her job and then he
gets put right back where he belongs in
a male prison and I'm not going to call
him she because he wants to call himself
she of course of course he does he's not
ashamed he
he said hey is it my only best raped
women with his penis it's ridiculous so
that's where the madness goes if you're
not very careful and in the lost in all
this are people on the trans side for
example I know some trans people who
feel that they're just being made
laughing Stocks by this debate they feel
that the woke
efforts to try and protect them have the
complete opposite effect that actually
they make the they make trans people
look ridiculous well we've interviewed a
bunch of people like that trans people
on our show to talk about this very
thing uh but Pierce you uh you talk
about tribes and one of the interesting
things for me was when I was on your
show you were talking about how you're
more liberal than not yeah and I don't
think anyone that I know in our old
industry the stand-up comedy industry
like we are sitting right now in their
eyes with the King Gammon you know the
sun The Daily Mail yeah you have my book
wake up Anyone who reads that book will
know that I'm what I would call an
old-fashioned liberal the kind that
tolerate other people's opinions the
kinds that believe that like I said I
mean all the issues we've been talking
about are all in here the identity
politics is dangerous the woke mentality
is destructive it's basically a new form
of fascism and that's why they don't
like me
because secretly they kind of now I'm
probably ideologically not far from them
I'm just not a nut case like they are
and the moment I say in that case on
your pocket there will be people writing
and saying they used to it how dare you
how dare you you must be fired you'll be
literally mental health and it's
obviously
um so I say read that book and you'll
get my look I don't really consider
myself to be ideologically left or right
I'm a journalist who likes to take them
all down and expose the hypocrisy on
both sides really that's fundamentally
my ideology is they're all probably
scamming us so let's call them all out
and get to the truth all I care about is
getting some out of the truth which is
increasingly hard when people think they
can have their own version of the truth
and call it my truth as if somehow
that's different to factual truth it's
obviously an absurdity but that's what
people think so I think that you're
right A lot of people on the left assume
I must be some right-wing headbanger
because they probably see a few Tick
Tock clips which are taken in isolation
where I'm saying for instance the other
day there's a tick tock clip went very
viral it's had five million views
and it's me on International women's day
saying to a woman who had was in an
argument about
gender
I said so I can identify as a black
lesbian can I
and she said well that's ridiculous well
no it's not is it it's the logical
extension of what you've just said about
gender should be Limitless now in the
whole context of the whole conversation
everyone could see what I'm getting at
if all you've seen is a tick tock clip
of me saying I'm Piers Morgan and I'm a
black man there he goes again a
right-wing lunatic look at that Gammon
you know belittling black people racist
belittling
gay people homophobic of course there's
none of those things I'm simply saying
if you have Limitless gender if you can
basically put your hand up and say you
could be whatever you want if you just
identify as it that's what happens and
if people don't believe me look at the
Scottish rapists who literally took it
to the worst possible degree
and got away with it
um so that's that's I think they don't
like me calling them out on the logic of
their arguments because a lot of it is
illogical now Bill Maher in America is
one of my favorite commentators
in the world but he's on the left he's
probably like me politically probably a
liberal guy really at heart and he finds
them completely insufferable the white
Brigade insufferable and and of course
it's not electable this kind of
mentality most people aren't like it we
go down Kensington High Street and you
talk to 100 people and you put five
worked positions I think you're nuts
should be putting some Asylum but do you
not worry peers that we talk and we
focus on gender and workers I mean look
there's something that we need to talk
about but you're a journalist you
realize that this country is in a dire
dire situation and financially
economically societally and it just
distracts from that and we don't talk
about it that's why you're wrong I'll
tell you why because it's not a small
thing
actually the way that we tackle big
stuff are the kind you're talking about
it comes down to leadership how can you
be a leader if you can't even say what a
woman is
who's going to follow you who's going to
take your lead what kind of person are
you a secure style is very impressive in
many ways I like him personally but he
just refuses to say what a woman is
Rishi sumac to his credit for antivirum
immediately said it's an adult human
female
right it's not difficult it's not a
trick question that's the answer
biological sex is just an irrefutable
fact so when a politician can't answer
that and answered your question he might
be leading the country in two years time
Kirsten a man who won't say what a woman
is because he's too scared does that
come for you doesn't come for me
so I don't think these are small things
I think the battle for
freedom of speech we saw it with Gary
lineker again recently the battle for
someone's right to have an opinion the
battle to save what I call old-fashioned
debate the battle against this woke
fascist mentality that you will agree
with us or you will be destroyed take
care rally must be destroyed at all
costs the order of political correctness
all that has got to be fought and won
otherwise the rest of it can't get fixed
you're going to end up with leaders who
are incapable of leading because they
can't even answer basic questions
because they're too scared so that would
be my answer that it's not they're all
interlinked all about leadership it's
all about Freedom it's all about
understanding that what the Cornerstone
of democracy is is freedom and the
moment you infringe on that right to
freedom for the British public the
American public for any so-called
democracy that way hell lies is that
where you're heading into fascism
hey Constantine do you like being
healthy of course in my country we judge
Men's Health by his ability to wrestle
bear turns out in London Russell bear
has very different meaning
we've all had a night that's got out of
hand
[Applause]
we will speak no more of this the secret
will be buried with my ancestors well if
you want to stay healthy and not feel
like you need to be buried with
Constantine's ancestors then you need to
try ag1 ag1 is simple and easy way to
get all nutrients you need each serving
contains 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients one scoop and you feel like
real men we use it on our America Tour
where we were constantly on the Move
living out of a bag and working every
day ag1 meant we felt great look great
and we avoided getting sick one scoop a
day meant we knew we had all the
vitamins and minerals needed for the day
we had hugely successful trip it is very
economical and I felt strong enough to
wrestle American bird which we all know
is grotesly weak compared to Great
Russian bird if you're looking for a
simpler and cost effective supplement
routine ag1 is give
vitamin D and five travel packs with
your first purchase go to
athleticgreens.com
trigonometry that's athletic greens.com
trigonometry check it out and become
real men like me
do you think peers as well part of the
problem is so be in the days of Blair or
Thatcher they had to liaise with the
Tabloid press in order to create a good
story in order to create positive
headlines but now politicians seem more
and more to be at the behest of Twitter
and Twitter is its own world and a
politician can be plunged into its
Twitter storm for saying something which
we all know to be true 20 of the public
are on Twitter in the UK and the us
about 20 of the 20 80 of the noise is
made by 10 of the twenty percent
and it tends to skew to the extremities
of the debate on right and left more
more left than right actually so you can
create get an impression of all this
stuff being sort of sanctioned by the
majority of course it's not it's why
Twitter gets everything wrong you know
Twitter assumed Jeremy corbyn would be
prime minister assumed Hillary Clinton
would become president assume Donald
Trump would be completely uh wiped out
in 2016. it assumed brexit would never
happen you know it just makes all these
assumptions based on the 80 percent of
the 10 of the 20
screaming away that that's what's going
to happen but it's not what 80 of the
public you don't even know what they
think you haven't asked them they're not
on Twitter they're not howling away all
day now I love Twitter as an information
source and as a source of stirring up
debates because I'm in the debate
business and if you ask me what my job
is it's to create debate on television
in columns on Twitter it all feeds into
debating for me I like a good argument
always have done
um and I have a real problem with people
who can't argue without throwing my toys
at the pram in a way that is ludicrous
well they just want to cancel you having
an opinion I think it's pathetic but
yeah to me the fundamental cornerstones
of these things all come back to the
basic principles of the Democracy which
is free free speech freedom of
expression freedom and the moment you
start to infringe on that it's all over
well appears talking of Freedom one of
the things that I'll be honest with you
surprised me when I did your show in
person afterwards I said mate now that
we're good mates how about you on block
me on Twitter and you went oh I've
blocked you on Twitter and yeah I made I
take the piss out of you overcovered and
that's when you surprise it because you
went yeah I deserved it yeah I did not
expect that actually given your public
Persona I've changed my mind on a few
things with kovid because the science
changed
so I'll give an example and I'm quite
happy to admit this and talk about it
and people's like ah there you go yeah
because to me it changed so I'll give
you a classic example
I uh when they said that vaccines
couldn't transmit the virus I said okay
right in that case anyone who doesn't
have the vaccine right now represents a
clear and present threat to spreading
this virus and killing people so your
selfish bastards and I'm going to call
you out on that and by the way those who
do have the vaccine they should have
more freedoms because they're not going
to better transmit it once they've had
the chat you are and you don't care
very strong very emphatic based on a
completely erroneous scientific
assessment which was it couldn't now you
might say well you shouldn't have said
it anyway I would sort of agree I would
say something else actually which is I
think that you have a duty to be
skeptical as a journalist that is your
job I've learned a lesson in the
pandemic about that definitely
definitely and I would totally accept
that I think I was too strident anyway
got two kind of wrapped up in it all but
you know I had good reasons for it I had
you know one of my colleagues at Good
Morning Britain Kate garraway her
husband was in a coma from covid I have
four or five friends and family who lost
loved ones how to say goodbye to their
parents on FaceTime and Care Homes where
they ripped through and so on so I was
very like emotionally invested in it
probably too much so for a journalist I
accept that but on that key point of the
transmission the scientists then said
but later actually it turns out there's
not much difference between whether
you've had the jab or not for
transmission and at that point I
realized everything I've been saying was
completely wrong
and completely unfair and then it
becomes a personal choice if you want to
now again someone will say well it
should be a personal choice anyway well
yeah yeah
but if we had for example as one of the
Oxford AstraZeneca professors put it to
me if this had been the plague come back
with a 30 to 40 death rate including
kids
how would people feel then if we had a
vaccine that was proven to be largely
successful and stopped transmission
and people were refusing to have it and
we were seeing not three thousand people
died a day but 50 000 died a day I would
say that people's views of that argument
might change quite you wouldn't need to
force anyone to take a vaccine if it was
the plague because right so what my
point being that the argument would play
slightly better if there were much
higher numbers of people dying right
which would come back to my sort of
thing that if the principles are
principal it doesn't really it shouldn't
really matter what the scale is but I
totally accept my rhetoric was over the
top and I think that people once it was
known that you could transmit it whether
you've been jabbed or not I think it's
entirely your personal decision to then
have the vaccine or not and that's a
complete u-turn on what I thought but
the scientists of the U-turn so I was
basing all my emphatic passionate
rhetoric of what I believe desires to be
another lesson from the pandemic science
evolves facts change they find out more
information I don't think as some people
do that all scientists are evil I don't
think they're deliberately setting out
to mislead people I think they're trying
to get to the truth it was a novel virus
early on when there were no vaccines and
no hope of any there's never been a
coronavirus vaccine so in those first
few months when people were dying in big
numbers there were no therapeutic drugs
really no vaccine and it looked
incredibly serious for mankind at that
point I felt the only answer was the
blunt instrument of a lockdown as it
went on I think the argument for
lockdown became less and less convincing
and I always believed that all the
subsidiary effects of lockdown on other
health issues heart disease
cancer and so on we're going to come
back and and haunt us the question then
was where was the pendulum on that deal
look Francis and I both supported the
first lockdown and actually someone
quote tweeted a tweet of mine from the
very first moments when I was saying we
need to work together and stop thinking
solely about ourselves and and people
are now using that against me so I know
I know that the position that you're in
but I think the one thing sticking with
the theme of Freedom that we've been
talking about that I found very
concerning is the amount of censorship
that was happening of scientists very
prominent scientists including Noble
David Davis who was a guest on our show
I made this point Nobel prize-winning
scientist being censored for talking
about things that are in their area I
agree right all of this I totally agree
I totally agree I think that was
um it was everyone slightly lost their
minds
and people will say well you're banging
on about Freedom where were you for the
freedom of people to espouse views you
didn't agree with on covid and it's a
tricky one when a lot of people are
dying but of course the whole point of
fighting for freedom is sometimes a lot
of people die for Freedom so I can I
totally accept that and I've evolved my
opinion if it was another Health crisis
I would probably behave rather
differently I think we all would yeah
that's true it's the same I would say
the same thing about
um when I campaign against guns in
America I was a British guy telling
Americans how to lead their lies they
have 420 million guns we have hardly any
and so what do I really know about their
gun culture the truth is I thought I
knew better than them and shouted them
louder and louder to try and get to give
up guns and they sold more and more guns
because of my shouting so the complete
opposite effect to what I thought and if
I had my time again I would dial down
the rhetoric and I would try and have a
much more open and constructive debate
or I would even suggest a stop calling
it gun control call it gun safety how do
you make it safe I know you can't take
all the guns away so how do we make it
safer much more interesting conversation
than a British guy who with an accident
like mine we'd been driven out with guns
to get them Independence in the first
place
um
got it right with me I think he said to
me please look the smart crowded like LA
and and New York the small liberals he
said we can't have all agree with you
right you're right it's Madness this
gun's thing it's madness he said but
most of the rest of America thinks who's
this snotty British guy with this
British accent telling us what to do so
it'd be like you're going to Germany and
saying they can't speed on the Autobahn
again the smart liberals be like he's
right too many people die on the
Autobahn people we should reduce speed
and the rest of Germany's going I don't
want to hear this from this guy and I
definitely don't want to hear it from my
accent and um he's right he was right it
would be like an American coming over
here and saying what a bank Cricket
because you know people people get
injured and what would we do we said
start off annoying American go back to
him you know that's what we would think
right so I broke that sort of cultural
rule which is you don't go to someone's
restaurant and uh you don't go to
someone's house and tell them their
curtains suck you might think but anyway
I hope they'd change their curtains but
you just don't shout at them yours your
curtains are disgusting because it's
it's their cat
um so I think that I've I've learned
definitely through that I've learned
through the pandemic that it's the
primary function of a journalist is to
be skeptical of everything
and to be open to all opinions you know
I would qualify it slightly there were a
lot of demented anti-vacular who are
completely implacably opposed to all
vaccines who were peddling utter lies
about the vaccines and I so I make no
apology for taking them head-on they
were really the people I was targeting
but when I look back at some of my
tweets
around the issue of vaccine transmission
I made a presumption the science was
always going to stay the same and when
it changed I was made to look stupid and
dictatorial and freedom bashing and all
the things that I hate
and that was a wake-up group
wake up
but Peters moving on so you started in
newspapers and you saw the the absolute
beasts that were the Tabloid newspapers
at the time they were so powerful the
reality is they were great yeah that's
just for the record the British tabloid
press is the most vibrant Dynamic press
in the world and from All Parts the
mirror I edited the mirror was left wing
these little world was right-wing I did
both and I will always defend the
British tabloid press here so you can
call them a beast I call them a wondrous
entity flawed yeah not perfect but wow
did people in this country have to be
concerned about the Press holding their
feet to the fire and that's what you
need in a democracy I agree with you but
the reality is that press is no longer
anywhere near as powerful I think it was
last year A couple of years ago the sun
declared 62 million pound losses which
for a paper like the sun is and was
unheard of
so where are we moving now and well
we're moving online I mean there's no
doubt you know my kids are in their 20s
I don't reprint newspapers they've read
everything online but they do read
newspapers online so I think there's
going to be a migration bit like in the
music industry how long that takes I'm
not entirely sure but you can see the
grass on all the circulations have all
been steadily falling in a miracle two
and a half million a day when I was
editing it back in the 2000s early 2000s
and now it's probably I don't attempted
that so there's no question away the way
the graph is going
um but there's also no question that the
digital readership of all the papers is
rising pretty fast too so it's really
what happens when it all washes out and
you end up with just digital papers
which will be the next Generation after
mine aren't going to buy print
newspapers I would I would lay an even
bet in the same way they don't buy Vinyl
Records so I think that that's coming
but it doesn't mean the influence has
changed I'm not so sure I think a great
front page of the song why don't you ask
Matt Hancock how influential the Sun
newspaper is because it was him and his
Shenanigans being put on the front page
of the sun led to him having to quit his
health minister in the middle of a
pandemic so I'd take issue with their
with the inference of papers like the
sun don't have that influence they've
still got it I mean just ask politicians
but still wake up and check the front
pages and make sure they're not on them
but surely if young people aren't
engaging with them as much as they used
to that therefore means they're no
longer as powerful they are engaging in
a different way they're reading tweets
from these papers they're reading stuff
that goes viral from these papers
they're disseminating the content
they're just not disseminating it in the
old-fashioned way of buying a newspaper
and sitting down in the cafe and reading
it like I like to do still do still get
five papers a day and sit in a cafe and
read them I love the feel of newsprint
my sons don't give a damn about that
um they don't read books in print form
they read them on Kindles and stuff it's
it's just a I would say that the
information is still being disseminated
just the mode of travel and the way it's
being
put around and published if you like is
just radically changed and is much
faster yeah but also as well they're not
making the money they used to make isn't
that a significant problem Pierce that
if it depends on how much money you can
make from a digital site a lot of them
are making good money from a digital now
so that will take time because you're in
that mid period now of this slow death
of print papers and the inexorable rise
of digital and obviously a lot of
advertisers at the moment are still on
the print side but they will move over
time 15 20 years time I'd be amazed if
there are any national print newspapers
whose print sales are still much of a
force I'll just be amazed just based on
numbers of my kids and their mates I
don't reprint newspapers so that clock
is ticking I think it's ticked longer
than people may have feared actually
um and can you make a lot of money out
of digital papers absolutely you can
absolutely so I don't share the Doom
Laden view I think everyone thought
about it about records you know stop
selling records uh you know it will get
streamed we're going to make the same
money they all make a lot of money no
one should worry about the record
industry yes and sticking with the theme
of Journalism one other thing that
things that occurs to me is you're
someone who has dealt with
very powerful newspaper Proprietors in a
very direct way and that everyone has
got an opinion about why Rupert Murdoch
does what he does what what drives these
people who want to own a newspaper or a
media Empire what do they want
well thank you Rupert murdo's case he
likes
um being at the center of things you
know he always has done that's why he
likes owning newspapers television
stations movie companies or publishing
houses
um these are just one of the world's
great media figures and in my opinion
the best
certainly I've ever worked with or full
um there's something about having
somebody at the top of a company where
it's their train set as I discovered
when you go for a company like ITV which
has a lot of engine drivers but you know
they're all dependent on their next
standing up in front of shareholders and
they can be bullied by Meghan Markle
into getting rid of presenters of hot TV
shows that doesn't happen under someone
like ruper murder because he he wouldn't
even take the call from Megan so I think
that there's a power that comes if you
work in that environment and I listen I
owe him an awful lot he'll never get me
saying a bad word about what have you
learned from him he's he's an
unbelievable Maverick that he backs
himself
absolutely backs himself to the extent
that he has the most extraordinary
vision for things Sky News is Sky Sports
revolutionize the way sport was covered
you know the way when Sky bought the
Premier League what absolute game
changer for football in this country why
is the Premier League the best in the
world Rupert Murdoch
I mean bottom line doesn't get the
credit he deserves but it was
you'll never see that in the profiles of
Rupert you'll see all the devil stuff I
did in myself as a devil on the front
page of the mirror when he was trying to
buy Manchester United beat him up in in
pointy ears and uh and horns and said
Red Devil you're the only person in
Britain who thinks Rupert Murdoch should
know Manchester United raise their right
index figure he was going like that I
think he quite admired the work because
I was a rival editor it would have been
a nightmare if they'd bought man united
because the sun would have got all the
exclusives so
um I think he I just think he's driven
from my estimation Rupert was driven and
still is just by news he loves news he
loves being at the center of what's
Happening knowing what's happening and
he loves the vibrant and dynamic
reporting of that commentary on that
that's what I think gets him up in the
morning you just can't wait like me to
find out what's going on and what are
people thinking and who's doing what and
who's going to run the country and it's
all intoxicating to him which is to me
well this is one of the things Francis
and I wanted to ask you both is what
still Dr I mean you're very famous
you've got tons of money I assume you
know you you you know I can even afford
a meal in here
what why do you do what you do you could
be on a beach somewhere for the rest
well I don't do it for money and I mean
I I like to value myself correctly but
that's a different argument
um I don't do the money I I do it
because I like being at the center of
things too I love it I guess I'm a News
Junkie so for me waking up you know I
wake up at five o'clock in the morning
normally and the first thing I do get to
Twitter what's going on what have I
missed what have I missed
you know when I'm on holiday the
nightmare my wife will tell you that
I'm one of these people that if I get
cut off from information I become a
twitching wreck
if I if she just lets me do my thing and
just every hour and check what's
happening I'm very relaxed I can have a
nice holiday but you cut me off from
that supply chain of of stuff happening
I'm a nightmare but isn't there a part
of you when there's a Twitter storm or
see everything explodes in the Zeitgeist
and you get pilloried as you know the
enemy of the people whatever they want
to do it's funny is it funny too isn't
it hilarious
absolutely there is a bunch of Geeks in
their mum's dungeon screaming abuse is
hilarious okay but when the people when
the mobile market Twitter storms last
about 36 hours yeah they haven't got the
energy these people these young wokies
haven't got the energy or commitment to
stuff I can wage feuds of people for 20
years with great Passion they give it 36
hours they moved on to somebody else
they haven't got the energy or
commitment but when people are calling
you racist for example that has got to
hurt well it's just it's just dumb but
I'm in a good position I've got nearly
eight and a half million Twitter
followers two million Instagram
followers I've got a pretty powerful
platform I've got a show that as every
day in the UK Australia and America
right I can create a lot of noise back
if I want to and I don't hesitate and
that's one of the good things about
Twitter they can tell me with their 40
followers you're a racist and I can
reply to 8.5 million people no I'm not
you're the problem and then what
normally happens is they delete their
tweet and then you see 10 minutes later
account deleted I call it vaporizing
yeah it's a bit like a star trip and
it's a zap things just disappear I like
vaporizing Twitter accounts have you
always had this thick skin yeah I don't
know I think my only real talent is
thick skin
in the sense that I think everything
comes from that for me my ability to
soak up crap and just let it wash off me
is an ability I've realized over time
not a lot of people have to the extent
that I have it and the and the
resilience streak you know my favorite
movie scene is Rocky in the sixth film
when he finally has it out with his
spoiled son in the street and he gives
him the speech about life being
tough place it's gonna beat you down and
it's not how hard you can hit it's how
hard you can get here get back up and
keep moving forward and that's how
winning is done I love that speech
because that to me is my view of life so
to my sons they'll they'll cringe if I
mention Rocky in the speech to his son
but they know they know instinctively
I'm right I said nobody wants nobody
cares about a whining Mona is just gonna
play the victim all the time nobody
cares you might think they do but they
don't they don't wallow in bad stuff
short of death and terminal illness
everything is survivable and thrivable
from I'm living proof of it a number of
times I've had people write me off he's
finished we got him this time he's done
he's a really I'm fine thanks
but that's a mental reason did you get
that pierce I think my family are very
strong people my mum's very strong my
grandmother was very strong dad's strong
you know my brother was an army colonel
um served in wars and stuff that gives
you that very important thing
perspective I think a lack of
perspective is one of the problems with
young kids today why they're so anxious
about stuff they don't really have a
perspective I used to say they had it
easy compared to previous generations
and statistically they did but actually
in the last few years they've been hit
by a once 100 Year pandemic a new war
Aging in Europe you know cost of living
crisis are likely
housing crisis something they have been
here with real problems and they are
actually discovering perspective the
hard way which is a lot of people going
through some really bad stuff so you
getting all upset about an exam result
or you know your car being dented or a
girlfriend or whatever it may be
you've got to get perspective and it's
not as bad as you think I can guarantee
you it's not as bad as you think but as
I will say to my sons whatever always
come to me I said have you got something
bad because the likelihood is I've done
something the same or worth
and they look at me and they laugh again
I went really really I'm 58 you don't
get to be 58 in with my career
trajectory and not I've probably done a
lot of things and you think God got over
that somehow came through it especially
in the public place
so I think that being able to do that
having a thick skin having mental
resilience uh is really a crucial tool
of life and without it I think you
really struggle I never feel anxiety
only about Arsenal
you know in the running now to the
Premier League if we don't win now I
will be a bubbling wreck but other than
football honestly I know nothing makes
me anxious live television doesn't being
attacked on Twitter doesn't uh losing
jobs doesn't because I've learned over
time I normally get a better one with
more money
um you know nothing I don't think is
ever irrevocably bad it just it's down
to you though to change that narrative
don't expect other people to
if you're fired on a Friday by Monday
most of your mates have gone back to
work and couldn't care less they'll
think about you once a week
reality check so don't expect everyone
to keep calling you and stroking you and
saying it's all going to be okay and how
can we help get on with it
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
this is a part of you that thrives on
conflict peers absolutely love it why
this is fun
yeah I'm like you I couldn't imagine not
thriving on conflict because that means
you never express opinions you never
argue with people it basically means
you're a Dullard
and who in the world wants to be a
Dullard
someone who just sits there soaking up
stuff never challenging never
questioning never falling out with
people
I mean I love all that stuff making Up's
always such fun
nice long lunch with your sworn enemies
yeah I even did it with Jeremy Clarkson
this scar on my head is from his right
fist at the British press you've made up
with Jeremy Clarkson at the Scarsdale
Pub around the corner he messaged me at
one in the morning and said Morgan
Clarkson here drink
Scarsdale Monday what 7pm everyone see
you there we went in like old old enemy
combatants you know and um what I
remember is he got very drunk on Rosie
which I thought was a bit girly no
offense
I was drinking pints of foaming hell
like Alan Partridge and uh we got blind
drunk and then his daughter turned up
and I realized we had to have one of my
kids for the peace settlement I called
my eldest boy on the phone and we put
him on and we had a formal piece
settlement the handshake was made and
the war was over I think it's still
simmering slightly it wouldn't take it a
lot we were in here one night and wine
was raging we had an argument about
something it wouldn't take a lot the old
scar would start twitching and I'd be
like my Army brother was like you didn't
hit him bang it's pathetic
any regrets Pierce when you look back at
the career I'm Edith BF
to my to my veins what's the point
regret is such a waste of energy what's
the point you gotta think about it what
I mean about changing minority you're
much better off expending energy on
changing your narrative doing something
which stops people looking back on
something that's gone wrong for you that
is a key part of my resilience of my
thick skin is like I sit there and
everyone else is going oh God you know
whatever and I'm sitting there thinking
what's next what can I do what can I do
and to be able to get to where you want
to get you've got to have a fresh head
and all of a sudden people when you get
fired from a job or whatever or you're
involved in some Scandal whatever it may
be go and clear your head just take four
or five months agree go to a beach go
and get fit go and do yoga whatever you
want to do clear your head turn your
phone off don't get engaged don't spend
every minute of the day fretting over
what your next move is going to be if
you've got a clear head
you'll start being offered some
interesting things you'll make the right
call because you've got clear head and
then when you're ready to go again
you're full of energy and you're fit and
you're ready to go that's been my
experience and then you can hit the
ground running whereas if you wallow in
what's happened and think how unfair it
all is hey nobody gives a honestly
outside of your family and closest
friends nobody cares I'm not sitting
there at home when I've been fired or
whatever with people going poor old
Piers Morgan they're like great we got
in this time Jump on his grave step on
his head and I know that I'm I'm
laughing
uh because I think I'm gonna have the
last love on you love is that it because
I'm like that I'm like yes I'm gonna
show you yes and it's going to be so
satisfying when I do it's gonna piss off
all the right people so gloriously and
who are the right people to piss off
peers
um wokies
wokies are the world's most ludicrous
people now
because they've become the very thing
they profess to hate most they become
fascists and they can't even see it
and so they want to cancel everything
they want to shame everything they want
to destroy everything they want everyone
to think the same act the same have the
same beliefs have the same values enjoy
the same films enjoy the same Rewritten
books enjoy the same statues
you know celebrate the same parts of
History that's called fascism
literally what fascists do to a country
that would have been here if people
hadn't fought for freedom in the way
that they did and those people gave
their lives so that we could not only
express opinions but so that we would
listen to people his opinions we
completely disagree with and we would go
you know what you're entitled to your
opinion and we seem to have lost that
more and we have lost that and and yet
ninety percent of the public that I talk
to maybe more think it's terrible that
we've lost that where's their voice
actually it's probably people like me
fighting that fight for them and do you
think that's why you get the ratings
that you get you get people following
you is because you are willing unlike a
lot of people in the media you are the
one who actually Strays from the party
line you're the one who challenges I
think it takes a certain amount of balls
to put your head over the parapet in
this environment
that's what I would say I'm not going to
blow too much smoke up I'm I'm backside
I don't mind doing that obviously
um but I don't I just think the reality
is you've got to have some people
prepared to have this fight and it
doesn't make you popular
although if you walked around with me
for an hour you'd be amazed at the
number of people would come up and say
thank you for what you're doing even if
they don't really agree with you I'm
saying
because Free Speech matters to people a
lot more than I think people realize
and Pierce another thing that might
surprise people given the public
perception of you in certain circles as
you rightly say actually the Twitter
circles is everyone I've spoken to and
every time I've done your show the
people who work for you they really like
you really yeah they do well don't tell
anybody there's almost like a
sycophantic field damaging and and I've
done your show on ITV I've done your
show and talk TV that theme seems to be
constant and you know we know people
used to work for you way back when and
ever no one has a bad word to say about
you unlike out there in the media where
everyone has a bad word yeah but it's
interesting isn't it because
a lot of the journalists will base their
perception of what they think the public
Think of Me based on Twitter which is
full of linear things whereas again if
you walk around with me I never get any
crap in the street until from anybody
whether I'm in New York La Sydney London
Scotland it's Universal normally
people laugh they smile when they see me
and we have a laugh right and it's not
because they agree with everything I say
at all in fact quite the opposite
sometimes they just like the way I say
it and they like the fact that I have
the balls to say it to say what I think
and that has really resonated with
people I don't get any problem at all
when I walk around nothing I can
remember one person after the Megan
Markle debacle was that what my daughter
walking in the park and one of my sons
and I was literally mobbed by about six
or seven people different groups of
people coming over who wanted to show
the support a crazy period after that
and then this woman came out it was
obviously a guardian reader she had this
sort of pinched face you know vegan
looking head
tight helmet too tighter it was cramming
her Cranium in and she just came on me
said you're all revolting revolting
people and my daughter was like nine or
ten just went include me
that was funny but it was uh but that
literally I could count on one hand
um
yeah I mean I just thought it doesn't
happen it's a Twitter thing and then the
mainstream media assumed because the
Winter's blowing up at me all the time
that's what the public think but they
don't
not in my experience I mean maybe they
all do and they just lie to my face but
that's not the British way so I think
the Twitter is is a fantastic tool but
it also skews a lot of things like I
said it makes people assume all sorts of
things are going to happen which never
happen and it also creates an atmosphere
around high profile people which often
Bears no relation to the truth JK
Rowling is hated on Twitter
but I bet you ninety percent of the
British public probably agree with that
certainly probably more yeah yeah
um and they look at what happened with
the ray business Scotland and they think
well that's exactly what she was talking
about exactly that's it right there
that's why she's right
and yet for expressing her opinions and
turning up at an event two doors down
the windows of this place got bashed in
which I know you've covered on your well
we had James on the show to talk about
it yeah really outrageous outrageous
and to me the Hub of those particular
types of opinions seems to be the BBC
now
where do you think the BBC goes from
here because oh it's so simple
I actually think what they should do is
have a license fee for the BBC News and
current affairs and all the things that
come off that and if you want to pay it
it's voluntary like it is for Amazon
Netflix all the rest of it but if you
want to get pretty unparalleled news
coverage largely done I think in an
impartial way all be by a lot of people
who often in their own lives are not
remotely impartial so there's a slight
bias which comes from the fact I was
joking shoot a harpoon around the BBC
Newsroom and not hit a conservative but
I do think that most of their output is
pretty down the line but I would say
news in current affairs and charge a
subscription for that and everything
else
just make it completely commercial right
sport entertainment why shouldn't it I
mean they're all Express opinions all
day long I'll imagine the day for
example I did Gary denica a football
presenter can't express an opinion
and the current rules are so vague about
non-news people it was Laura coonsberg
or Hugh Edwards the main news people at
BBC of course they can't express news
opinions but Gary then again
you know standing up as he would see it
for refugees
really is that going to have any
material effect on how people vote in
this country no
what it did do actually was
raise a big light on the policy which
probably hasn't worked out for the
conservatives quite how they hoped
because it Shone a light on some of the
problems with the policy
um but as for Gary's ears a friend of
mine full declaration but I would say
that if it was a right-wing presenter I
mean there aren't many who admit to
doing that but if it was somebody who's
who agreed with the small boats policy
for example I would defend their right
to have that opinion I actually wrote a
column saying I don't agree with what
Gary said
actually I think he's very naive about a
lot of this now when you've got whatever
it is 30 odd percent of all the people
coming over on small boats turned out to
be young economic migrants from Albania
a safe country clear the system is
deeply flawed and you should be able to
say that and so a lot of them won't left
refuse to accept even that
demonstrable fact which I think is
ridiculous
um but in Gary's case obviously you
shouldn't have compared it to 30s
Germany I just have a rule of thumb just
trying to leave
Hitler's out of here
anybody anybody and then you get
ludicrously when people start comparing
him to Putin and you're like what's the
difference you know
um but so I think it was all a bit crazy
but at the heart of it is free speech
and I think that the BBC problem really
is the license fees are anachronistic my
son's not going to pay a license fee it
is not yes uh before we wrap up and ask
you a final question another friend of
yours or maybe form a friend of yours
looks like he's going to run again
Donald Donald yeah big Donald sure he's
running here
what what do you think about that is
that going to be a good thing for
America I'm hearing the same stuff I
heard in 2015 that he hasn't got a cat
and hell's chance of winning absolutely
he's got a chance of winning if he wins
a republican nomination and that's
probably going to be the toughest
challenge he has I would say that
cyclically are people going to want
another four years of Joe Biden given
how old he already seems
um and dodgery has to be unkind for a
moment but he is dodgery he's 80 he'll
be 82 at the election 86 at the end of
his next term if he runs again I don't
think people will vote for that over
someone like Trump who's never had a
drink in his life never had a cigarette
never had a drug so for mid 70s he's
unbelievably full of energy I mean not
crazy compared to mine so I think he
would beat Biden actually this time
um
and he always does get the nomination
but I don't think he can get the
nomination I think Republicans are going
to Veer to someone like uh Governor Ron
DeSantis in Florida I think but with
Trump everything's unpredictable and
when it's going to be a good thing for
the world
well look with Trump I always felt if
you took away all the rhetoric and the
tweets he took away all the things that
make Donald Trump Donald Trump you have
to take all the things that come out of
his mouth make him very electable as we
saw yeah you take remember 10 million
more people voted from Second Time
Around the first so we took four years
look at him and like what they saw in
America yeah right he still got beaten
but he had the second highest number of
votes in history second time right so
we've got to get these things into
perspective and I spent a lot of time in
Middle America doing crime documentaries
in Alabama and you know Arkansas and uh
you know all these places Miami and uh
Dallas and you get a very different view
of trump when you're down there in New
York and L.A I always say that I
wouldn't put it past him he's got a lot
of legal stuff going on and who knows
where that all goes but I've not seen a
real Smoking Gun yet with him which
could I think bring him down or prevent
him becoming potentially I mean look can
you imagine if you won again the
inauguration speech the gloating it
would be literally insufferable but he
could do it he could have never been
against it one thing of Loma Trump he's
a very he's got extraordinary Charisma
and I don't say that necessarily is a
great compliment you know you've had
very malevolent political leaders you've
had extraordinary charisma I don't want
to mention him but Hitler would be one
right I thought you were going to say to
Jeremy corbyn
you know but you have but you have
malevolent dictators like Hitler and
others who Mussolini they've all got
great Charisma and that enables them to
inspire a big following Trump has that
he's not as malevolent certainly as
those two were but he can be quite
malevolent in some of the things he does
but he's often with him or the way he
says does and what his actual policies
are is actual policies he simply took
him on policy they were quite popular
with people petroll your borders lower
taxes you know be America first I mean
if you don't think most Americans go
along with all that they do so I think
that he his problem is what comes out of
his mouth and what comes off his fingers
um that's been the problem with him
um so I think it's everything to play
for if you're going to be him as a
republican candidate then I think you're
definitely going to have what it takes
to be president because is the biggest
battle they're going to face when they
get on that first debate stage whoever
it is they know Trump is basically King
Kong and he's going to try and smash
them all down one by one and it's
whether any of them can beat it that's
going to be fascinating to watch did you
like him or do you like him
I do like him
yeah
he does things that I hate but then I
think I've got a lot of friends like
that you know there are lots of people
like that who I like but they do stuff I
don't like you know
um so I just don't I I don't think he's
the devil as some people think and he's
certainly not as Angelic as some of his
more die-hard supporters think I think
he's somewhere in between but I will say
to my liberal friends
on on migrants for example how many
migrants did Barack Obama Deport in
eight years
and there's always a stunned silence and
then I say well give me a number
and this is people from the smart crowd
here and in America and then they start
guessing and they go in eight years uh I
don't know 100
000 and someone else would go half a
million someone say 10 you know because
that's the presumption that Barack Obama
must have been a really nice guy with
migrants and the actual answer is three
million arguments were deported under
Obama which is the highest Pro writer of
any president ever
and he was known as the portrait in
Chief in Mexico
you know he campaigned in 0809 to shut
down Guantanamo Bay because as a legal
brain he thought this was unconscionable
and it's still open
you know he dropped more bombs in his
last year than I think any American
president in modern history he launched
all the secret drone programs you know
there's another way you can skin this
cat with Obama being actually doing some
pretty bad stuff that liberals gave him
a pass for and Trump doing a lot of good
things amid all the Mayhem which he
doesn't get enough credit for
you know I would look at what he did I
mean he didn't go to war in four years
pretty amazing the only Jimmy Carter in
modern times has been another president
could say that
um he always thought said to me he just
thought war was too expensive which is
the Trump we're looking at it wouldn't
be about people dying just too many too
expensive but you know but to his credit
America didn't just start invading
places when he was president
um he took on Isis very effectively
um you know you'd look at the way that
perhaps Putin and Kim Jong-un and others
reacted to Trump and behaved around him
it's an interesting point would Putin
have invaded Ukraine if Trump had been
present I'm not sure about the answer to
that question certainly worth thinking
about because he was unpredictable and
it's a great asset actually for an
American president to be unpredictable
Biden is very predictable
yeah appears well thank you so much been
a great pleasure we're going to ask you
a few questions from our supporters that
only they will get to see the answer to
but before we do that uh final question
is always the same what is the one thing
that we're not talking about as a
society and I know that you talk about
everything you think what is the one
thing that we are not talking about as a
society that you really think we should
be well also winning the league
volunteer people are talking about that
I I think my honest answer would be I
think the biggest crisis facing young
people is mental health
and what we're not talking about is the
best way to combat mental health
problems I'm not talking about
diagnosable mental illness I'm talking
about clinical depression and things
like that I'm talking about this
epidemic of anxiety and I think we're
going about it completely the wrong way
so I would like to have the mental
health debate completely reframed into a
constant barrage of influential
high-profile people talking about as
I've done a Miss interview about mental
strength and resilience and thick skin
and dealing with life's problems I'd
like the Rocky Balboa speech to his son
played on Loop in schools every morning
at assembly I'm serious right instilling
kids that normal life share is not life
ending right because what's happened in
the last few years The more I've noticed
that we talk about mental everyone being
mentally ill and suffering from acute
anxiety and kids being depressed and all
these things the more we've talked about
it I've just noticed the more of it
there's been
the more anxious they've got the more
depressed they've got almost like
they're all kind of wallowing now in
this world of misery that they're
constantly being told there's things
wrong with them rather than celebrating
what might be right about them and
focusing them on that and getting them
out of this thinking I mean the number
of young kids now a university taking
antidepressant
medication is terrifying or anti-anxiety
medication I was young we didn't even
have those things
you had to have a bigger skin just to
get through the day right and now it's
just like there's a constant crutch but
I I don't like the narrative from the
top down I all these celebrities talking
all the time about I nearly killed
myself I nearly did you know I've had
acute depression I've got OCD I've got
Biz I've got PTSD all of them have got
20 things wrong with them and they talk
about it all the time and then all these
young impressionable people are looking
and watching this and hearing it
thinking oh yeah I've got that I've got
that I've got a self-diagnosing hitting
Google and then before you know it
they're all medicated up that's what's
going on so I would like that narrative
to change I couldn't agree with you more
man and it's actually one of the reasons
that I oppose wokeness so much is that
it's training people to be fragile yes
well it's telling them not only to be
fragile but you will be celebrated for
it and there's money in them there
fragile Hills you can be a celebrity and
a success story just by saying I've got
all these things wrong with me
it's a great point to finish on Pierce
thank you so much for coming on the show
recommendations everybody get the book
of course and uh we will see you very
shortly with some questions from our
local supporters but for now thank you
for watching and listening we'll see you
very soon another brilliant episode like
this one or raw show all of them go out
7 PM UK time and for those of you who
like your trigonometry on the go it's
always available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
do you think Megan will dump Prince
Harry
foreign